hi there Steve here I'm sorry to be a
couple of minutes late
you know these systems like Google
Hangouts so I go first of all Google
Hangouts or YouTube now has a new
formula for live streaming so every time
I go there as I go to the beta first I
don't want to go to the beach I don't
want to learn anything new so then okay
go to the you know old format I find
that so I do that and then and then it
comes on and ask don't trust anything
you get do you really want to trust a
CGI trust and then I got a blank screen
and then I have to get out of it and all
this stuff
unreal anyway I guess in the end it's
all good stuff it enables us to
communicate but that I think very often
the programmers try to be too clever
tonight one of my and so there's an
issue there of control we want to be in
control of our destiny and so when
people and just people can criticize
link for the same when we come up with
something new we think is better and
people aren't used to it and may in fact
it may not be better for many people may
be better for some people not for other
people so we feel we're out of control
here we had something that we felt we
were in control of and now somebody else
has done something to us and I find that
the you know the classroom is a kind of
is kind of like that the classroom is
essentially a space controlled by the
teacher now we're all on our 90 day
challenge we are in control we're
focused for 90 days to improve in
whatever language in my case it's Arabic
and Persian and I decide what to do and
that's a great feeling
so for example I decided that because we
have a week to go here formally I guess
the 90 days ends on the end of the end
of Mar or the end of April rather so
that's gonna be next Wednesday thirty
days has September April June next
Tuesday next Tuesday it ends
so and I want to finish off with a video
in Arabic and the video in Korean so I
want to prepare a bit so I've decided
I'm gonna cut off my Persian for a while
and focusing on Arabic try to get my
level up then have a discussion with
someone in Arabic which I will a video
and so people can assess my progress or
lack of progress and then I'm gonna
spend three four days focused in on
Persian and then other the same with
Persian so I decide what to do
I've also decided because I was in my
bookshelves here I came across this book
here called complete Arabic and one of
the good things to do in any language
learning situation is to go back to the
beginning go back to the beginning and
if possible if you go back first of all
if you go back to the beginning stuff in
a way it's fresh because you haven't
been there for a while and second of all
if you go back over the beginning
material with a different book or a
different set of materials that's all so
fresh and so I decide to do that so
again I make the decision but then I get
into this book and you know the things
they do it like they'll spend like I was
listening to the audio this morning
while making breakfast and so they've
got like five minutes on telling time so
if I were in a classroom and the teacher
decided we're gonna work up telling time
like for the whole hour we're gonna just
tell time I'm not that interested in
telling time it'll come eventually
it's not a big part of what I want to
achieve early in Arabic so but the
teacher would decide or another session
in the audio the audio by the way is
available for streaming on their website
so I I don't know where I bought the
book maybe I bought the book in London
and I can stream the audio off their
website so I can stream it on my iPad so
I can listen on my air pods
while it's being streamed on my iPad and
so it functions us listening material so
then they spend another good five
minutes on numbers and you know twelve
thirteen they say it one twice and they
even have I think
is extraordinary this complete Arabic
teach yourself they have English people
non-native speakers doing the Arabic I
think that's extraordinary
it's okay whatever but I think that
detracts from the authenticity at any
rate if I want to spend an hour on
numbers I can do that but I typically
won't and if you're in a classroom the
teacher will say today class we're gonna
do numbers or we're gonna do colors and
so the teacher gets to decide and I
think that's bad for learning now maybe
I'm just a bit of a rebel at heart I
still remember in grade four at school
we were in art class and I was drawing a
hockey player because to me that was the
most important thing in the world a
hockey player so I drew the hockey
player with hockey pants and with socks
the way you know the hockey uniform is
and my teacher our teacher was from
Germany and in Germany they didn't know
what a hockey player was and since then
my hockey player was skating she said no
no and she over my hockey pants
she drew ski pants and I still to this
day from great for I remember that how
dare she
impose her idea of what a hockey player
should be wearing and I kind of thought
there whatever you know and I think this
is a big issue this issue of of control
I often on I think I mentioned this oh
and I should say by the way that that
the book I often referred to by Manfred
Spitzer learning and the brain I mean he
makes the point learning doesn't take
place in the classroom it takes place in
the brain wherever the brain is and in
fact I tweeted I said the teachers
dilemma is that teachers in general are
quite dedicated to helping their
students improve however the most
important thing is not what happens in
the classroom the most important thing
is what the teacher does excuse me what
the student does outside the classroom
you know I was at a
conference many years ago in this large
parking lot both learning or these
languages and Professions and studies
showed that in Germany for every hour of
instruction from a teacher language
teacher companies pay for language
teachers
the average student spends one hour one
hour a week so for one hour in the
classroom they spend one hour on their
own on average that's nothing that's not
gonna achieve anything the job of the
teacher is to find a way for that
student to spend ten hours a week and by
the way when I'm in Ukraine in l'viv I'm
gonna be giving a talk to or not a TKE
to a group of language teachers
presumably English teachers that work
for a large IT company in the vivre and
I'm also gonna focus on that that your
job has teacher it's it's not so much
what you are able to teach in that
classroom it's to what extent are you
able to motivate your students to go out
and listen and read and do things on
their own and decide what they're
interested in listening to and reading
and if they're interested in numbers or
telling the time fine they can focus on
that sometime and but if they're
interested in something more relevant to
their work then that's what they should
go after and they should go after that
and listen and read outside that
classroom I think one of the real
failings of our education system is this
idea that the teacher and it's on both
sides is both the teacher and the
student the student says teacher is
going to teach me and the teacher thinks
I'm going to teach them and really the
job of the teacher at least insofar as
languages is concerned is to motivate
them because any explanation of the
language any resources about the
language are abundantly available so how
can you guide encourage stimulate the
student to really go after the language
that's the task and it's funny you know
you see this in so many different ways
again on Twitter some teach yourself you
know my language class is not about
teaching the Spanish subjunctive it's
about teaching social justice well you
may think that's important but I'm the
learner and if I think learning about
the Spanish subjunctive is important or
if I think watching Colombian telenovela
is important then that's what I want to
do it's not for you to dictate what I
should be learning about and and when it
comes again this comes up not only a
language instruction you hear it all the
time you're gonna teach critical
thinking know the more you know about a
subject the better your critical
thinking ability so the better you can
read and they're more widely you read
the better you're able to make your own
assessment judgment about different
situations it's not up to the teacher to
impose their assessment their judgment
their subject their timetable so
admittedly maybe I'm a bit of a rebel
but I think that's extremely important
that both the teachers and the learners
understand that at least when it comes
to language and probably not only
language but particularly language where
there's such an abundance of grammar
information and language content it's so
much the audio rich video music is so
much stuff out there that the task is
that the teacher is to persuade the
learner that the key is not what happens
in the classroom the key is what happens
outside the classroom now this means
that teacher has to recognize the limit
of their role and has to limit the
amount of control that they want to
exercise over the students and allow the
students the independence and encourage
them to be independent to go out and
explore like I hear that there are
teachers who won't let the student go
forward in the textbook you know we
haven't covered that yeah you can't walk
you can't go there
you know the student has to be
encouraged to go forward to go backward
go back to the beginning jump ahead
explore the language so today so anyway
we're in our last week I'm focusing I
spoke Arabic yesterday I thought I did
better than I have been because I was a
bit focused in I've got another Arabic
conversation at noon today I'm gonna be
focusing in on Arabic till about
Wednesday or Thursday when I will do a
video in Arabic talking to one of my
tutors and then I gotta focus in on
Persian do a video on Persian and then I
will have completed my 90 day challenge
so with that I
we'll have a look and see what sorts of
comments we have and we can carry this
conversation and people like my glasses
I like them too I bought them in Lisbon
was a rainy day
I forgot my ten dollar cloud or tenure
glasses at that hotel we were wandering
around I can't tell you near the Bairro
Alto and there was a you know shop there
selling glasses so I went in there with
the intention of buying and other cheap
pair glasses so I could read the menu at
the restaurant and the person that
persuaded me that this was the way to go
so that's what I did and these were like
70 euro which is a lot more than I was
intending to spend on the other hand I
enjoy them very much
no let's open this up and see what sorts
of questions there might be okay so bla
bla bla bla bla second place to the bang
I'm waiting you aren't helping you so
better the guys in Southland the title
of the video is quite strong we do learn
languages in classroom especially when
the classroom is our only source of
comprehensible input now why would the
classroom be the only source of
comprehensible input the likelihood in
the classroom is that the teacher may or
may not be a native speaker the other
students are not native speakers
anything you look at in the classroom a
book or if you listen to audio it's all
come from somewhere else that they there
is an abundance and absolute abundance
of input everywhere if you're using link
you can bring it in and look up the
words and phrases you can find podcasts
which you can transcribe
there is also an abundance of material
with both audio and text so I don't
understand gusta Pamplona here saying
that the classroom is the if you
consider the classroom your only source
of comprehensible input you are not
sufficiently independent you need to
take more initiative hey is it true that
there are more
languages you learn the easier learning
the next language becomes if so why
khalifa' khalifa' i have found that to
be the case and I'm not an expert but I
would say that the reasons are the
following so when we are born we can
learn any language doesn't matter you
could be born to a Mongolian you can be
burnt to an Indonesian to a swahili
speaker then if that's the environment
those are your parents those are your
friends your brain will gradually form
around that language initially it's
completely flexible it's a free-for-all
by the time we're 6 or 7 the brain
starts to get a little more rigid and
it's optimized for whatever language we
were surrounded by now when we learn a
second language we are now introduced to
new sounds new structures new ways of
expressing things so initially with only
one language that's very difficult but
once you have been able to create some
space in your brain for that language
the new sounds the new ways of
expressing things then the third
language now you are already a little
more flexible so you don't find some
other way of expressing things strange
you have a wider range of sounds so your
brain becomes more able to assimilate to
integrate a new language that's point
number one now I'm not a neuroscientist
but that's the way I see the process in
the brain the second thing is because
confidence is such a big factor in
language learning until you have
actually achieved fluency cheap fluency
in one language you really don't think
you can do it now once you've done it
once
now you're confident so after I have
achieved fluency in French I had no
doubt that I could learn Chinese there's
no doubt in my mind a friend asked me
when I was assigned by the Canadian
government to go to Hong Kong to learn
matter he said but yeah but what if you
fail that thought had not entered my
mind I had learned one language I can
learn another language so your
confidence is greater and the third
thing is you have a better sense of how
to go about it I discovered with French
and this was reinforced with my Mandarin
learning that you need to read and
listen
that more than any explanations that
you're gonna forget or not understand or
whatever you know grammar tables that
you won't ever remember it's that
reading and listening so I had a method
I had the confidence that I could do it
and I think my brain had become a little
more flexible so that is the answer to
that question from halifa
hi Steve big fan is very hard from
Russia just from saying hi Andrew yeah
you know what I had a great time in
Russia and I want to go back and you
know I'm a great fan like I believe the
one thing about languages we learn them
we lose you know I saw a quote someone
in Britain saying that Britain is an
exceptional country and it's very
pessimistic to say we're not exceptional
every place is exceptional
there's nothing exceptional not about
the United States Britain not about
Russia but all are equally exceptional
and all are equally you know exciting to
learn about as I'm learning now about
our big countries in Persia but I really
enjoyed being in Russia and I saw so
little of it I only saw st. Petersburg
and Moscow and I would like to explore
more of that country um you know how can
I improve my speaking alright to improve
your speaking it's kind of like two
things you want to build up your
potential to improve but then to really
improve you have to speak a lot what do
I mean by that all right to improve your
potential you have to have words first
of all you have to understand because if
you're gonna get involved in meaningful
conversations with people you have to
understand what they're saying so you
have to build up your vocabulary you
have to build up your listening
comprehension therefore you have to read
and listen a lot comes a point there
where now you're you're bursting at the
seams you want to start trying to use
what you learned even though you won't
remember much of it like yesterday I
spoke in Arabic and I was searching for
words that I know I have but I couldn't
find I couldn't remember the words but
I'll do it again and again and again and
I'll get better and better and better at
retrieving the words that I have already
sucked into my concrete you know passive
vocabulary
I understood most of what my air
cooter was saying I had trouble finding
the worst and I need it eventually you
have to speak a lot speak a lot without
worrying now obviously that's easier
with a tutor because then I'm paying the
tutor he has to listen to me or she or
it might be
eventually you get out and talk to
people who you are not paying and who
are not your friends there it can be a
little more stressful but you just have
to focus on communicating and speak as
much as you can all right
how can I prove my genius no I lost I
pressed the wrong button here now that
wasn't very good and I see if I can get
back to it okay
excuse me here I press something on my
iPad which knocked me out of there I was
will get back in there okay where are we
now I was thinking okay how can I deal
with low motivation I'm committed and
erm to learning language but there are
constantly mood swings which arise make
me unmotivated occur okay yeah I mean we
all have swings in our motivation one
good thing is to just because we're all
creatures of habit if if I'm in the
habit if I'm doing any tasks around the
house I go and search for my ear pods
and I start listening so and when I
listen then there parts that I don't
understand and that motivates me to go
and read it up on link so that the a lot
of it is triggered by the listening so
if you have the habit of listening
whenever you have an opportunity that's
gonna create some curiosity that'll make
you want to read that text so I'm always
dealing with audio for which I have the
transcript and I can read it on link and
look at words review the words so the
audio triggers the curiosity also
reading a text or hearing certain you
know for example the verbs in Arabic
which is completely confusing and you
know you plural male and female you
plural female you poorer a male and
trying to remember the ending for the
past and the present very complicated
every so often I get curious I look it
up so it's that you have the habit of
listening which then causes you to go to
the text then you see things that you
might once again look at the rule how
does that really work or a table and
then you go to a grammar table
that's kind of how I maintain my
motivation isn't always comprehensive
cuz teachers most of them learned in the
traditional grammar is the only source F
yeah my famous is right like
unfortunately a lot of the classrooms
are based on grammar instruction and so
the teacher decides today I'm gonna
teach the class whatever it might be the
subjunctive or case endings in Russian
or something all of that teaching is a
limited benefit unless the students have
already have a lot of exposure to those
structures through a lot of listening
and reading so very often the
instruction doesn't achieve an awful lot
the teacher then can test them on it and
if it's just been taught at them they
may even answer correctly but two weeks
later they won't be able to do it if
they haven't developed the necessary
habits through lots of listening and
reading what does my mother tongue says
Jayesh okay well the language that I
speak most naturally is English when I
was born in Sweden so for the first five
years of my life the language I spoke
most easily was swish but when we moved
to Canada I was a five years old we
transitioned we spoken only English at
home I transitions to English I went out
to play with kids five year old in the
neighborhood I have no recollection of
ever having any difficulty communicating
obviously I must have spoken with an
accent but we were just kids and pretty
soon I had forgotten my Swedish and the
only language I could speak was English
uh-uh
but seeing things over and again after
like makes you see things from another
perspective yes Roma how do you find
content for target language I'm here
which target language okay in the case
of Arabic week I had to create these
mini stories so I paid to have someone
translate them from English record them
same with who is she so that's created
our Arabic some of our Arabic content
members of link have added and a whole
bunch of other content for
Persian same thing again we created that
content then I paid for some other
people to create some content then I
found Persian online I googled Persian
sometimes our Google in the target
language you know in languages that are
easier like mentally polish I wanted to
find audio book an e-book on Polish
history the same with Ukrainian I just
Google in Polish in Ukrainian I find the
content I want I imparted into link so
the other thing you can do is ask on our
forum at link ok how do you ok I see the
word to check I'm gonna do Turkish I
don't understand what you've written
there but my schedule is basically
ignore the Ukraine so I want to work a
month on my Slavic languages I want to
get a little better at cases of verbs
and stuff like that then I want to work
on my Korean because I go into Asia in
the fall then I'm gonna get back into
Persian and Arabic and probably add
Turkish because there is obviously a
real cultural linguistic historical link
between the Arabic language the Persian
language and the Turkish language and
that's part of my exploration of that
part of the world
hey Malthus never you know generalize it
all to use or not what is the best
manner to teach second language for
children obviously it depends on the age
of the children I mean I have a friend
in Montreal
tetsu whose father is from Taiwan
Chinese mother is Japanese his wife now
he is Japanese he lives in Montreal so
he has a strategy he and his father
speak to his kids in Chinese his mother
and why speak to the kids in Japanese
the children go to French school in
Quebec they don't Quebec they have a
spanish-speaking nanny from Mexico what
are we after Chinese Chinese Japanese
French English Spanish so that's one way
of doing it and these
young toddlers you know I haven't had to
deal with that I tried to get my kids to
learn languages they resisted you can't
get people to do things that they don't
want to do including your children so I
have no further wisdom on this I think
he's put out a bunch of information on
this subject
one person he I think he calls it one
person one language so that in the
family but person I couldn't do that
like we all speak the same language you
know even though I can't speak other
languages my wife his big other
languages in terms of our family
environment we speak my mind
in anyway uh hello I'm from Peru I'm a
Spanish native speaker name is my second
language
I'm not motor to learn French okay so
Karina Isabel Valderrama for a Spanish
speaker to learn French on the one hand
you have most of the words once you
understand how they switch to like
Spanish and Portuguese that what they
call the the lexical proximity the
similarity in words between French and
Spanish is over 80% English and Spanish
is 50% by the way because there's lots
of Latin origin words in English so you
have the words it'll be easy for you to
remember the vocabulary that's the good
news the bad news is that French you
know it's a bit like Spanish speakers
learning Portuguese you have to accept
that it's a different language you have
to get out of your Spanish pronunciation
you have to really try to project
yourself as a French person a French
speaker and really tune into how they're
pronouncing the words for example the e
at the end of a word is not a hook
that's one of the very common mistakes
that speakers of Italian or Spanish make
when they speak French you know instead
of saying you know sure they say J
instead of say saying Palmer
they say paw upon the head like that o
becomes a head that o is an important
part of French pronunciation so you have
to really listen to the language get
used to some of the phrasing there are
some differences in
so if you're prepared to really plunge
yourself into French and not hang back
in your comfortable Spanish environment
you can learn the language quite quickly
but it's not so easy because it's you
know the words flow together I mean
every language seems as if it's spoken
very quickly by the native speaker
Spanish to us to non-native speakers but
in French it's like everything kind of
blurs together so you do have to do a
lot of listening um an English assist
Ellis's videos good if you think
learners will learn faster if the
teacher instead of talking sorry I start
again okay do you know how much the link
to this charge to make a private
mini-story lesson about 15 minutes for
you we pay we have now many of our mini
stories have been provided free by
volunteers where we are we're unable to
get volunteers for what we consider
major languages supported languages we
have paid and I think we pay four
dollars we have paid four or five
dollars a lesson for both the
translation and the recording now if
it's a new mini story in other words if
you want your tutor to do something
you'd have to negotiate with the tutors
it's I would presume you pay the same
amount as you pay per hour for a lesson
what's up Steve okay I wish my tutors
revealed to me that this unit is not
memorizing recovery and it's all about
enjoying the language in my free time
and living it yes and he sees it
Java in schools your name implement a
language learning foundations course
they should like I would like I missed
one and I'll go back to but Charles I
agree I think they should they should
have language learning experts in
schools not necessarily someone with
credentials in Spanish French Chinese
but someone with who has really studied
language acquisition and can help
students learn any language like why
would you say well we can't offer
Chinese at this school because we don't
have an accredited or a credentialed
Chinese teacher you don't need a
credentialed Chinese teacher there's so
many resources on the
what you need is a person who
understands how to learn in the 21st
century
how to stimulate learners how to get
them to do things help them find
resources people as verified content
help them find content in other words a
language learning class telling students
how to learn and letting them go out and
learn whatever language they want to
learn rather than as is in as is the
case in Canada imposing French on them
you must learn French or in the u.s.
presumably Spanish I don't say I don't
learn French I want to learn Swahili
here's where you find Swahili resources
and then work with and help them and
find dictionaries and all of this kind
of stuff that's my answer to you Charles
now oh here it was do you think learners
will learn faster if the teachers
instead of talking listen well I think
there is evidence that where the
classroom where the learners are allowed
to read in the classroom where they
allow are allowed to listen in the
classroom that they do as well or better
there was an example in New Brunswick
which is a bilingual province in Canada
in the French language system they
didn't have enough money to hire an
English teacher so they made a bunch of
audiobooks and ebooks available to the
students the students could choose what
they wanted to listen to and read and
that's all I did
and after two years those students did
better not only in comprehension but
also in speaking they had advanced more
quickly than the students in the more
structured structured formal class think
about it just by choosing what they
wanted to listen to and what they wanted
to read on their own those kids ended up
learning faster than the kids in the
structured classroom No
so true I learning it from movies games
TV series yes what's able to follow the
lead Iike cousin analytically bigger
than this oughta be lots of things
sure lady car if I understand correctly
there's there's a music to each to each
language there's
intonation to each language there is a
sort of inherent genius of that language
to express things a certain way in
Japanese in in Russian in French and you
kind of get in tuned to them and you
enjoy it that's part of what makes the
language fun and and it's the beauty of
the language so some languages may sound
more beautiful to people who don't speak
them so if you listen to Dutch you might
say lots of you know harsh sounds but
I'm sure if I started learning that I
would find this intrinsic cleverness and
beauty in the way the Dutch language
expresses things yeah here's an ED and
he sees it again I had a few teachers
that hated if I read in the textbook
yeah I mean that is just ridiculous
teachers do that all the time
don't read ahead I'm the only source of
knowledge here I will tell you what to
learn you can't learn on your own not
very clever I know man says teachers
should teach us to learn independently
yes I've been teaching for 31 years if
the teacher has 15 students in a
classroom the teacher may need 15
different course plans to meet the needs
of each student that's a big challenge
no maybe you don't need a course plan
period Jo maybe you don't need a course
plan there's the language there's books
there's audio go to it what course plan
in addition to motivation feedback and
answer questions also counts in language
teaching yeah where the students want
the feedback absolutely encouragement
feedback answering questions but also
the student should be encouraged to
figure out where they can get their own
answers so rather than asking you know
how do I say this in Portuguese this
presumably is from Brazil how do I say
this in Portuguese or some issue of
grammar the student if the goal of the
teachers to make the student independent
the student should be shown where they
can find that information like there are
online dictionaries there are
online grammar resources the teacher
needn't be the only source of wisdom
about the language why is it that when I
listen and read my brain tingles from
the front to the back I don't know
Annette Andy do I get tired when I don't
understand no no I consider it normal
not to understand sometimes obviously
it's it's fun to go back to easier
material where you understand it all but
then are excited challenging to order
more difficult period material where I
struggle and then I'm tired of that and
I go back to easier material but it
essentially doesn't bother me
ASMR ok I will look that up if it
happens when you concentrate intently on
sounds it could be ASMR how much time
does it take Oh somebody asked me about
a hundred links a week I've been making
a hundred new links a day for the past
week I think this is too few links for
starting a new language no 100 links a
day is good Daniel Johnson good that's
very good 100 links a day but I don't
set myself a goal I want to make a
hundred things a day
I just got add some content and start
linking and so it's again I'm sort of
motivated by my interest in the language
in attacking new material in learning
new words don't necessarily set myself a
goal hmm
no how much time does need to get second
language the level of my native language
you will never get your second language
though to the level of your native
language that's not a realistic goal how
long does it take to achieve fluency in
a language it depends on the language
depends on how fluent I prefer to focus
on just enjoying the language and just
seeing how far I can get in the case of
English does having a mainstream accent
British or American importance and
fluent
okay to my mind
fluency is not related necessarily to
the accent I know many non-native
speakers of English who are extremely
fluent and you have an accent as to
whether it's a mainstream accent I don't
know what the reference the mainstream
accent is in other words if you have an
Australian accent that's fine too
if you have a I don't know Irish
Scottish is all good or if you have an
accent that's identifiably not native
speaker that's also fine the fluency is
more about how you use words in reading
books and watching movies with subtitles
can be interchangeable I mean either
reading or watching and noting down
words and phrases that you don't know
well the trouble with movies is that
it's you know you got to sit there in
front of the TV or in front of the movie
at the screen the advantage of listening
is you can be anywhere about listening
reading of course you also have to sit
down but I find that reading where you
have no visuals you're just relying on
the words is to me more powerful but if
people like movies then that's good too
and watching movies with subtitles in
the target language is also a good thing
to do ok RR III irth finally hit a
breakthrough in Japanese understand the
media that took about one year you know
what that's a great comment because I've
often said that learning languages is
like a snowball so and or I've said you
know the rich get richer and the poor
get poorer the more words you acquire
the more familiarity you have with the
language the more interesting material
you can access this person can now
access the media and that's gonna
accelerate his learning it's gonna make
the learning more enjoyable it's gonna
ensure that he or she stays with it so
that we just there's this increasing
momentum as we as we acquire more words
and more familiarity with the language
yeah I mean teachers all teachers that
I've met have been very dedicated I just
wish they would encourage more
independence on the part of the learner
I have asked you many times but you
didn't help me about how to start my day
learning French at beginner level and
English at intermediate level well I
mean if it were me I've simply get into
Lync and I find content of interest and
depending on my mood of the moment
I do one language or the other and if
I'm a beginner in French then I will do
beginner material in French it's no
different than what I did with Persian
and Arabic you have to explore each
language on its own I decided in the
case of Persian and Arabic that I would
go the first half of the week in Arabic
and the second half in Persian that was
my decision I find that there's less
interference that way so I might suggest
to you that you decide to split your
time up that way you could also go three
months on one and three months on the
other it's going to depend on what you
are most comfortable doing
don't the listen if you're beginner
without looking at paper you listen from
yeah I do a lot of that I might
initially listen and read at the same
time but most of my listening is without
having anything in front of me because
that that's where I get in most of my
learning time is doing other tasks
driving exercising cleaning up and
listening okay how would you compare the
diversity Spanish import Spanish and
Portuguese and Mandarin and Cantonese
which is greater I would say that the
difference between Cantonese and
Mandarin is greater the in the finally
there are if you are dealing with a
newspaper article formal texts there is
very little difference between written
Cantonese and written Mandarin the
pronunciation of Cantonese the
pronunciation the very same character
very same word is easy so much more
different it's the difference between
the matter and the Cantonese
pronunciation is so great that a Madrid
speaker cannot understand the Cantonese
reading the same text cannot understand
what the company's speaker is saying or
understands very little so that the
mutual intelligibility between Cantonese
and Mandarin is is not as great but the
vocabulary is essentially the same
except for five 10% of everyday slangy
type conversation but for the bulk of if
you listen to a podcast from Hong Kong
on history most of the words used are
words that also exist in Mandarin
somewhat different usages times but
overwhelmingly the same vocabulary very
similar pronunciation very different and
then everyday language again quite
different Portuguese in Spanish like
Portuguese speakers typically can
understand Spanish I think
banished speakers can understand the
Brazilians more easily than they can
understand the Portuguese from Portugal
but when I was listening to Portuguese
podcasts from Radio Portugal it was not
uncommon that the Portuguese interviewer
would interview a Spaniard he would ask
his question in Portuguese the Spanish
speaker would answer in Spanish the
audience for all Portuguese speakers and
they understood what the Spaniard was
saying that would not happen to the same
extent so I would say that you know it's
not it's not exactly the same but but
Portuguese is closer to spending then
Mandarin is - Cantonese - so yeah I
talked about this for but please talk to
mark about an evening link available to
Chinese students without needing a BPM
high I will follow up on that and maybe
Eric here can remind me I don't know
what the technical issues are we have
spent a fair amount of time on China and
it hasn't worked out so we'd love to do
something in China but there are
technical issues I know Steve child pull
go you so you're young you're how many
died thank you think of another question
to ask the following person to fund this
game stimulating okay good I don't know
when the 90-day challenge if it's over
I'll stop making these videos I thought
it had to go to the end of the month
well I mean yes I talk all the time
about language teaching methods you'll
have to go through my videos
well gherkin where I'm studying in high
school in the US and the thought about
creating a lengthening Club to help
people how would you go about that well
you know I think sharing the big thing
is sharing your interest on your
enthusiasm
second thing is sharing resources all
the different you know sources of
content for different languages
different learning methods like a
language Keener's Club budding polyglots
Club and you share everything that you
all know about where where to find
resources to help you and how to use
them
okay
I had a Korean teacher explained that
linguistics behind the pronunciation I
have never found that helpful but
everyone is different
finally made one of these rests here
from is Emerson I think my earlier
posting is I'm using link respond love
it comprehensible and put us the way
Ross Bagley thank you started FSI
Spanish even though it's a bit dry
Sita's a new fresh approach to my
existing method which is random okay hi
Steve also the name onion SEO I want to
ask you about English life school I have
signed in and have arranged a plan to
building a large foundation improving
their skills fine you said you pay
people to create content for in Arabic
doesn't exact what kind of content they
create for you and what you wanted to
create Amir okay what we created
initially with simple stories the many
stories that link what I would love to
have in Arabic and not only for Arabic
but because I'm learning Arabic two
kinds of content one to Arabic speakers
now I realize this is a bit artificial
because people don't normally speak to
each other in Fatah entered it in the
Standard Arabic but if two people would
speak to each other in Standard Arabic
and then transcribe it so you have a
natural conversation and then it gets
transcribed because typically if people
speak to each other they use less
difficult words and it's natural it's
engaging so that kind of cost so simple
dialogues simple dialogues about
everyday life what you're doing at work
at school the kids
even politics economics a series of 20
dialogues 20 dialogues in a in Arabic in
Standard Arabic eventually we could do
the same in in Egyptian Arabic or in
Levantine Arabic that'd be one kind the
other kind would be and this could apply
to other languages as well the other
kind would be you know the Arab world
all right
so sort of discussions like let's say
five minute five max ten minute almost
like simplified lectures on different
aspects of Arab civilization before
Islam
Andalusia Baghdad Tunis Saudi Arabia
colonial period the modern period
politics the whole thing covering a
whole bunch of different subjects
economics society religion but
simplified this thing would be
intermediate content that could then
lead me to having an easier time with Al
Jazeera
so that was for Amir hi there if anyone
is entrant Thai you can take a look in
China I made us the video okay
we may get may get we'd love to have
tired link by the way if you would help
us create content for Thai so yeah in
school and university they give you
homework and you must do the homework
and of course the homework you do learn
something by doing the homework the
problem is you know there's so much
things we can learn if we go at it
independently but then we don't get
credit for it and so as a student you
are obliged to focus on doing things
that the teacher asks you to do cuz you
need those for your marks so it's a real
struggle I think you you know what I
would do is I would do what I'm assigned
by the teacher but my interest in the
language would inevitably inevitably
drive me to do more or less
and reading well I'm here I would have
to see a sample I'd have to hear a
sample of your audio and we can discuss
that separately you can send me an email
steve at link calm malaysian fan here
how do you learn new language though
forgetting the languages that you have
learned mad Ezrin i don't forget them I
don't forget them because I learned them
through massive input and therefore all
that remains I have difficulty starting
up again trying to speak but very
quickly I catch up to where I was before
and move ahead ok hi sig for the honza I
have never used it my son Mark used
heizak for Japanese no comment I don't
know but you have to find something that
works for you in order to learn the
characters because only when you have
the characters can you you know
obviously read and reading is key to
learning but watching YouTube videos by
reading articles stories in interval
time learn grammar sentence structure at
school but vocabulary I learned in my
own okay yeah but we can also learn
grammar and sentence structure just
through lots of listening and reading
and occasional reference to grammar but
we can also learn it as school Petra but
it's the education that demands to
follow a curriculum and have
quantitative results grade so it's not
always up to teach it this is true Maria
absolutely mr. Steve always had the
alarm okay hi Steve toughest challenge
learning Mandarin is the characters
basically that's the hardest things it's
not tough it's just a lot of time and as
quickly as you learn them you forget
them and you have to keep relearning
relearning relearning there again lots
of reading is a big help
nice thing and imitating isn't that an
effective way of getting into a language
yes yes hi I'm Mexican I'm starting with
my Japanese studies and I'm thinking if
I should focus more in the work average
that will help me not get stuck as much
when I try to
any advice I mean fire a pen 90 you the
brain has to get used to the language so
you struggle you struggle you struggle
but the more you listen and read and
listen to things for which you can get
the text that's how you're gradually
gonna get used to language and struggle
to struggle is normal and I necessarily
focus on vocabulary as sort of in
isolation from content I think you got
her again as we do at Lake Erie I study
then I I read I listen I review the
words a little bit I turn the page or
continue doing the same and I know that
eventually I will learn the language do
you think that being interested in just
one or two things about the language
history and culture are enough to keep
the motivation up during our learning do
we need more reasons I mean for me
that's enough obviously if you meet
people that you want to communicate with
or because I mean history and culture
that's a pretty broad range there okay
how many how many books have you read in
Russian approximately yeah you know
including short stories like Chekov and
you know play like Vespa Daniels Yama at
CGI tea
Anna Karenina whatever I forgot I like
the classics by the way I don't know
five or six I would say I struggled a
bit with the Master and Margarita yeah
five or six I have lots more that I want
to get to but pretty soon I wander off
into other languages I think learning in
a library is more effective than in a
home and way more effective in a
classroom is just better for focus what
do you agree actually learning in a
library is probably very good for focus
if you are alone at home it's more easy
to be this it's easier to be distracted
that I find sitting in an airplane is a
great place to learn because for
whatever reason these public spaces seem
to get me to focus more uh what perfect
steps oh well you know I've been through
the different steps to learning so often
reading does help especially bilingual
books okay I'm not a fan of bilingual
books because I find it distracting they
constantly have to read the other
language but whatever people enjoy hi
Steve also how do you think how many
books are language learner needs to read
to achieve the advanced level I can't
say but the more the better and I would
add audiobooks to the reading
I think audiobooks are tremendous and
and so my favorite sort of activity when
I get past the intermediate stage is to
import an e-book in the link get the
audiobook which I don't divide up into
audio files for each lesson that link I
just listened to it and but then I go
through the e-book learning the words
and phrases what was the question again
how many to read how many did I don't
know how many but the first book you
read and now away from the computer on
your own that's a milestone everyone
should read a novel oh yes audiobooks I
know some people who claim to be quite
fluent in French I gave them as a gift
an audio book a French novel they
claimed they couldn't understand so I
think you want to get to where you can
not only read a book but you can also
understand an audio book and
particularly the case of Russian again
it varies but some of the audiobooks are
so good it's so it's such a pleasure to
listen to them some if you don't like
the voice if I don't like the voice of
the audiobook you've cleared away
whatever I put in from Tunisia we cost
like that oh ja that is yeah how can I
make my learning more and more effective
well lots of listening and reading Keith
in D and you whatever D in you is gonna
do that Kenyan girl also listening or
reading can you get me Pro Keith
Hamilton
yes I'm arriving in nip row on the
evening of the 16th of May and I stayed
there till the 19th leaving the 19th
morning going into the Don Basque area
blah blah blah
selamat malam ceremonies for a long time
is telephone hour
tima go just keep going there is no
magic pill by watching Galileo but my
listening has improved but how can I
prove my speaking as well continue
listening and start speaking and when
you speak don't worry about it and the
more you speak the better you will get
is the content or the method the cure
for program procrastination the content
the content from Bangladesh okay at that
it's been an hour and I'm gonna call it
here so thank you all of you for
listening and yeah there's not many more
of these left before the 90-day
challenge is over so we'll see how far
what we have achieved bye for now